Nikki with the way she was murdered and
I've had a listen of it it's horrendous
for more than three decades Sharon
Henderson has fought tirelessly for
justice today her daughter's murderer
was finally sentenced but it wasn't the
sentence she hoped for well I thought
life would have meant life was so poor
I've been let down again by the justice
system that night in 1992 David Boyd
lured Nikki to a derelict building
beating her with a brick and stabbing
her 37 times in the chest
in sentencing Boyd the judge said Nikki
would have felt unimaginable Terror
Nikki must have been petrified
it would not have taken the
seven-year-old long to appreciate that
she was trapped in that cold and dark
building and that you were coming
through the window to get her the
original police investigation was
riddled with mistakes
of that offense the investigation was
reopened in 2017 with advances in
forensics allowing officers to match
Boyd's DNA to traces found on Nikki's
clothing decades after she was killed in
a victim impact statement read out in
court Sharon said that she fell after
the original investigation that she had
to fight for justice for Nikki and that
she was frustrated that she felt she
wasn't listened to but this time police
worked hard to prove Boyd was
responsible for us as an investigation
team we've had to go through all of that
material to look and scrutinize what was
done in 1992 up until 2013 and then from
when we've started as well so it's been
a real challenge
um from an investigative point of view
and that is why it's taken some time as
well to get to the point where we are
now so many things have changed in the
three decades since Sharon lost Nikki
who she called her bright and Sparky
child who had a beautiful smile but the
pain hurt and anger remain the same
shinki marike Sky News Newcastle Crown
Court